i had a conversation with someone the
other day about you know just like
modern times and all this
who's gonna fight the wars
yeah right who is going to
put freaking
black paint on their face and pick up a
weapon and crawl across the beach
and start killing enemy like that's a
certain type of human being right that's
the type of human being that may not
correctly reintegrate into society this
dude might end up robbing banks when he
gets back
it's the martin watson problem yeah it's
the martin watson problem which we'll
get to
but but we do have to think about that
and and
when you have guys you know we we talked
about obedience
as a characteristic being look it's is
it good to have some obedience yes it is
and was darby may be too far on the
spectrum of being too obedient yes but
then you get some other guys that are on
the other end of the spectrum that you
want you want to have someone that's
going to be like i don't care what you
tell me to do i'm going to go attack
this machine gun nest get out of my way
you want to have some guys like that
they're hard to control
but if you get rid of these guys if you
get rid of the charles shumstroms and
the watsons you get rid of those guys
your military's not going to be able to
function in my opinion it's not going to
be able to win it's okay yup you're
right it's not it's going to be able to
function probably going to be able to
function very effectively in a peacetime
environment
so my question you've commanded these
guys
how how i mean what what's the answer
how do you how do you you know take the
strengths of a of a sunstrom or watson
um but how do you make sure that they
don't go off the rails yeah what you
have to do is you have to put put the
put the guard rails in place and you
have to and it's not here's the the
interesting thing about this this isn't
that hard
this isn't where you've got to be
constantly monitoring every single thing
that they do you have a good
relationship with your guys
then when you say hey listen here's the
line we're not crossing it guys go yep
roger that and they know you're not
playing around they you haven't
you haven't uh uh shown them where hey
you know jacob says this but he doesn't
really mean that no it's like when i say
something this is what i mean
and this is what we're gonna do this is
what we're not gonna do
and and look i mean i had
guys that were definitely
actually i want to have guys just like i
just said i want to have guys they're
going to say hey if i can get if i get
the chance to do this
in a high progressive way i'm going to
do it you give me a chance to kill the
enemy i'm going to do it that's what i'm
going to do that's what i'm here for
that's why that's where i was born dude
tony of friday you know tony afratti
tony was a platoon chief in charlie
platoon tasking a bruiser i if
he would do anything to be able to go
out and kill the enemy and he would also
never cross the line of like oh okay
hey we're not doing that cool that's
then that's the line
and that's exactly what you want
um
and and what so so the question that you
posed to me how do you do it what you do
is you have a good relationship with the
guys
you explain to them what we can do what
we can't do and then you explain why we
can't do it
and there was um
uh i used to go and brief the jhz
classes the the junior officer training
classes and and i briefed mine okay well
there you go one of the things that
i used to tell these guys was hey listen
when it comes to
when it comes to the rules of engagement
when it comes to the law of armed
conflict you have to not just do what
you think is right you have to do what
you think what you have to do not just
what is you think is right but what is
legal
and here's the reason and and leif had
to have this conversation
life had a senior officer in the room
when i was explaining this to these
young guys like yourself
that
what's what people think is right
what you you take 16 seals and you say
you give them a case example of is this
right in your own personal moral code
you're going to get 16 different answers
you're going to get somewhere oh yeah
this this this person's uh insurgent
will kill them or this person's an
insurgent oh well we we should we
shouldn't hurt them because we can
reform them you have all these kind of
wild different answers
so what you the only thing you can
actually follow isn't what an individual
quote thinks is right
you have to follow what is actually
legal
and i made that i always made that very
clear with my guys hey listen this is
what you can do this is what you cannot
do
and here's why and of course in any
leadership situation it's important to
explain the why
and you know for instance in ramadi
there was a bunch of reasons why you
can't go out and
shoot an innocent person well first of
all yeah it's morally wrong second of
all everyone would know about it
immediately so it's not like it's not
like i could have a sniper going oh you
know i'll sneak in a shot over here no
one's gonna know no we're in a city with
400 000 iraqi civilians that we there's
a mayor there's a police force there's a
there's a governor there's a whole
there's teachers and doctors inside that
city
you kill an innocent civilian
everybody's going to know about it and
by the way all those iraqi government
officials
they have relationships with the brigade
commanders with the battalion commanders
with the company commanders we're all
talking
so if you think oh i'm going to shoot
some innocent person get away that
you're never going to get away with it's
not happening
and
on top of that we are now losing the war
when you go out and kill an innocent
civilian you're giving
you're giving propaganda to
the enemy
and you're creating more insurgents by
killing an innocent person
so you have to not just explain hey
legally you can't do this but also
here's why you can't do it